hey everyone welcome to the
behind-the-scenes for rush now you might
notice that this is a little bit
different than the regular vlog content
that's because these are true behind the
scenes we have one episode running
concurrently with every episode going on
go 90 talking about all the different
cool things we had to do to make this
series happen so I hope you guys enjoy
and one week rush premieres on go 90 I
hope you guys are excited we really are
this is the biggest project we've ever
done rush is free to watch and going on
you don't have to open your wallet
however you do have to live in the
United States sorry
the YouTube thing while it's been great
it's always been a stepping stone or Sam
and I for us to move on to make films as
time went on YouTube became more and
more of a serious business and we found
ourselves really just spending time
doing YouTube videos but recently these
past couple years he really tried to
push and continue to taking that next
step after doing sync which is like a
web series of so our other
feature-length narrative that had done
we finally got around to getting the
opportunity to do another film well you
know that we do a lot of live action
video game interpretations Sam and I
have always kind of believed that we
could do the video game rebe correctly
Sam when I grew up with video games and
we demonstrated over and over and over
again in our channel that we knew how to
bring video games to life and live
action
really there was a seed that was planted
we went out to the middle of nowhere in
the desert with Freddie and Brandon and
we filmed a commercial for Battlefield
it was a moment where we were still
getting into YouTube and we were still
kind of learning the ropes and we
basically ended up all kind of starring
in and kind of all co-directing a
battlefield commercial imagine for
directors on commercial
Madison make it work somehow because
he'll and one day to shoot 30 seconds
and usually we're shooting two minutes
in the day yeah so it was actually like
a quarter is easy and there's four of us
so it became an eighth is easy as usual
exactly
but yeah at that moment though we had
not really worked with a lot of video
game companies or brands or stuff like
that so this was our first opportunity
and there's a huge one basically we met
a lot of the people on the team there
and we got to know them things went
really well the commercial was awesome
it turned out hilarious and everyone had
a great time shooting it from that point
three years ago four years ago I don't
even know what it was but the point was
though is that that's when all the
groups came together to make this
project happen after working with video
games and all these companies for so
long we're just like we can do this
nobody else has done this and we've been
just talking with these guys on and off
and on and off leo over years and things
all changed about a year and half ago